Hello!
How is your linear algebra?
Are good at multiplying matrices, or at computing
eigenvalues or at inverting a matrix?
Yes?
No?
Well, you’re saved because this paper solves
9 linear algebra problems with… transformers!
Wait, Ms. Coffee Bean.
Why do we need transformers to this?
It’s not like we wouldn’t have exact programs
computing these things!
Well, thanks Reviewer 2 for ruining the research
mood by asking practical questions here and
doubting the usefulness of a transformer solving
linear algebra problems.
And to you, our viewer: welcome to this AI
Coffee Break, where we will explain how a
transformer can do linear algebra, and also
why this is a cool and a useful thing to do
in the first place.
But do you know what else is useful?
Ms. Coffee Bean that brought a sponsor for
today’s video.
Thanks to Weights & Biases for supporting
us for this video!
Now we can fill up our coffee machine and
the chocolate box!
And do not tell us that you were living under
a pile of Coffee Beans and did not hear about
Weights & Biases yet!
Weights & Biases is a Machine Learning Operations
(MLOps) platform, helping you to build better
ML models, faster.
It helps you track your experiments with beautiful
plots!
Did it ever happen to you that you overwrote
training settings for a special model, and
you cannot reproduce it anymore?
Well, with Weights and Biases, this will never
happen again, because all the configs are
saved!
And you can use Sweeps to optimize hyperparameters
while sitting back and drinking your coffee.
Surely, this luxury is super hard to integrate.
Wait, what, it isn’t?
You can integrate Weights & Biases with just
a few lines of code!
Okay, then how much money do I have to spend
for this luxury, Ms. Coffee Bean?
Nothing, because it’s free for personal
use and for academic teams.
All right!
Of course, if you’re one of the big players,
you have to take out some money of your thick
wallet.
But if you are a student like me who wants
to stay organized even in the advent of the
paper deadline when all your coffee beans
are going crazy and everything’s a mess
and irreproducible from that chaotic excel
spreadsheet you use for tracking experiments,
then you should give W&B a try!
Now let’s go back to our linear algebra.
In this paper, the authors say “we consider
problems of linear algebra…”
"We"?
Who now?
We, François and Charton, right?
Just kidding, we are laughing about the scientific
way of writing “we”, even when the paper
was written by a single author.
There are even better things to laugh about
when it comes to scientific publishing, like
for example the case of the physicist who
used his cat [cat sound] as a co-author to
conform to publication standards.
Read that story on Wikipedia, it’s linked
in the description below.
So, they, the authors, use a transformer to
perform 9 numerical calculations from linear
algebra:
Matrix transposition, matrix addition, matrix-vector
multiplications, eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
singular values and SVD and finally, matrix
inversion.
But why would anyone ever want to do that!?
It’s not like we do not have algorithms
for these problems already!
Why do matrix inversion with transformers?
Well, we have at least one reason we could
present to you: I think Ms. Coffee Bean is
not the only one who is curious to know:
What are the limits of what transformers can
do?
Can transformers be applied on text?
Oh yes, they can!
Can they process images?
Yes, they can!
Do they work on speech?
Of course, they do.
Can they do math?
Well, it depends on what kind of math.
We had a video where we explained the transformers
that do symbolic integration.
Transformers also have been shown to prove
theorems, do formal logic, solve SAT problems,
symbolic regression, dynamical systems, and
so on, see the paper for references.
So, for symbolic mathematics, transformers
seem to work well.
But how are they with numbers?
Luckily, this is what the authors are basically
asking too.
There have been investigations on sequence-to-sequence
models for arithmetic tasks, showing how transformers
do not work that well on this.
Check out the related work if you are interested
to know about this part.
But the linear algebra problems as chosen
by the author(s) answer a broader spectrum
of questions, from little easy tasks to complex
ones:
Can transformers do basic operations on individual
coefficients of matrices, like it is the case
with matrix transposition and addition?
Can they also do compositions of several arithmetic
operations, like it is the case with matrix
multiplication?
And then, can they even do complex nonlinear
transformations (with cubic complexity) like
the matrix decompositions and matrix inversion?
And then: What about generalization?
Does a transformer trained on one type of
matrices generalize to another type of matrices?
And also, what about few shot learning?
Can trained transformers be further tuned
to solve even larger problems by only a few
examples?
A few, this is few-shot learning, after all.
So you see?
The test here is big, ranging from simple
operations to more complicated arithmetic,
to advanced algorithms I learned about in
university, in my linear algebra classes.
Ms. Coffee Bean, to date has not heard of
them yet,
so she calls NumPy linalg all the time in
her blissful programmer ignorance.
But I see you are not convinced or motivated
yet to use the transformer overkill to solve
these problems?
Are you reviewer 2 here?
Then let’s look beyond the paper into even
more arguments made by the author(s) during
their rebuttal.
One argument is that is important to test
the limits of transformers if we want to apply
these to science, just think about Deepmind’s
AlphaFold in biology or transformers as a
replacement for Mathematica.
So the question is whether certain computational
building blocks can be performed inside a
transformer.
Because if yes, then one step is clear when
chasing the question of applicability of transformers
in science: they can do linear algebra.
One more argument that the author(s) make,
which Ms. Coffee Bean seems to like the most,
is that transformers are usually used as end-to-end
solutions.
Let’s suppose that for the solution, we
must compute some arithmetic operation or
some linear algebra.
It would be impractical (when time and resources
are critical) to “step out” of the transformer
to perform these operations, so having a network,
or a subnetwork implementing these operations
in neurons, is simply: comfortable and practical.
Two more arguments focus on providing general
insights on transformers that are small.
We are not talking about GPT-3 sized models
here, but about shallow, simple models that
one scientist can train on his GPU at home.
Also, the encodings, representations and insight
can be used for purposes other than linear
algebra.
Okay, Ms. Coffee Bean, enough with the motivation.
We got it; this is research.
It has all the positive practical outcomes
we just mentioned.
It’s fine to do something only because we
can and because we can learn something from
doing it.
It is research, it does not have to land directly
into the AppStore to make money out of it.
In any case, now that we are over-motivated
with transformers solving linear algebra problems
and we think that it is cool, let’s dive
into explaining how this is done.
Well, to work on matrices with transformers,
one needs two things: matrices and transformers.
Of course, the challenge here is to represent
the matrices, so the input, into a format
that a transformer can process.
The other challenge is to understand transformers,
for this, maybe you want to check out one
of our previous videos.
We remember that transformers work with sets
and, if the set's elements have an order,
we speak of sequential data.
The transformer encodes the order of the data
in positional embeddings.
And matrices have a structure, an order so
we need to somehow transform these two-dimensional
tables into sequences.
Nothing easier than this, one can do it by
taking the numbers and writing them one after
the other.
Their order would be then captured in positional
embeddings.
The author(s) also pre-pend a coding of the
size of the matrix.
This gives the transformer further information
about the matrix dimensionality so the transformer
can leverage this.
But what have we done, Ms. Coffee Bean?
By just writing the numbers one after the
other, we actually created a vocabulary for
the transformer of infinite size, because
there are infinitely many real numbers (the
last we checked).
So encoding each matrix coefficient with just
the number it represents, is a poor decision
because the network would need to learn representations
for the each possible number in the infinitely
sized vocabulary.
With an infinite vocabulary size, it will
surely happen that numbers occurring during
testing, will not have occurred during training.
Then is there a way to encode the numbers
better and maybe have them represent some
prior knowledge about numbers in general?
Yes, there are at least 4, as presented by
the author(s).
We are talking about P10, P1000, B1999, ... and
... .
Ms. Coffee Bean, stop it with the cryptic
codes, we are not talking about the Terminator.
So what is meant, is pretty clear from this
table, that one can decompose a floating point
number according to these rules and use a
set of integer numbers (still infinite, but
their infinity is smaller than the infinity
of the real numbers) and other symbols.
This means that the knowledge about numbers
is explicated.
For example, in the P10 and P1000 representations,
we explicitly have the information of whether
the number is positive or negative, and this
is explicitly stated in a separate token.
So yes, each number is tokenized into 5 tokens
in the P10 representation, so the sequence
length is blown up by 5 times, but this also
means that the sign of the number is a special
token in the vocabulary, so the plus token
is shared among all positive numbers in the
vocabulary.
If we get a new, yet unseen number during
testing, with the P10 representation, the
transformer will have an easier time: the
sign token is known, these integer tokens
are also known.
So there is a trade-off between how much a
number is decomposed into a known vocabulary
(making things easier) and the sequence length
(making things also harder when training transformers).
Cool, so now that we know how the authors
encode their matrices into sequences, they
just need to create training data.
How?
Is there a matrix database or benchmark lying
around anywhere?
No need, because one can generate random matrices
oneself for the input.
To generate the output, one just has to call
NumPy linalg and get the solution.
So say welcome to matrix-solution pairs, gather
your transformer and let them do their thing.
As a note, the paper does work with relatively
small matrices , like 5x5, 6x4, 2x13.
Of course, a next research question is postponed
for the future, about bigger matrices, thus
longer sequences for the transformer.
In any case, training processes later, the
author(s) come in to check onto their transformers
and how well they did on each task.
And well, surprise, 90+% accuracy across the
board!
At least within certain tolerance levels (neural
networks are probabilistic models, so one
cannot expect exact results in each matrix
coefficient).
Yes, there are some differences between encodings
where P1000 generally performs best.
But the short lesson here, is:
transformers do work on these 9 problems!
Feel free to gaze at the numbers in the paper
linked below.
Because the “real” question about neural
networks is: All-right, but how does this
generalize?
(This is AI researcher talk for asking whether
the model has really “understanding” the
task.
Ms. Coffee Bean, why are you using the word
“understanding”, that’s off limits.
Let’s reformulate: so the question is whether
the transformer has found the general algorithm
behind, let’s say matrix transposition,
so can it generalize to types of matrices
it has not seen during training -- that would
be generalization.
And this is what the author(s) investigate
in two ways:
The out-of-distribution generalization experiment.
In a nutshell: the authors train their models
with random n by n matrices that have the
property that the coefficients are independent
and identically distributed (iid) sampled
from a uniform distribution.
Matrices fulfilling this property are known
as Wigner matrices.
Okay, so we have the Wigner matrices.
How does a transformer trained on Wigner matrices
perform on other types of matrices (also present
in science)?
Well, if the test set is composed of matrices
with coefficients that just have a different
standard deviation than the train set, the
model only generalizes if the variance of
the coefficients in the test set is lower
than the training set variance.
If one increases the variance, the probability
to meet a number outside the training range
increases too and the model kind of fails
because it cannot extrapolate.
Ms. Coffee Bean counts this as a “nay”
for generalization.
We think Gary Marcus would say: Told you so,
neural nets do not extrapolate!
Okay, then let’s forget about the coefficient
variance and let’s look at the experiments
where the eigenvalues of the matrices have
different distributions.
Well, again, if the distribution changes from
train to test set, the results are again bad
if not catastrophic for some configurations.
Then what to do in order to generalize?
Spoiler: (carefully) adjust the training data.
What helps generalization is when -- hold
on to your chair --
the training set is enlarged such that its
distribution captures more of the different
types of matrices.
This goes exactly towards the point we made
in our video about foundation models that
of course “out-of-distribution” generalization
happens when we increased the training distribution
so much that the whole world was in it!
Yes, this paper is not enough to draw this
conclusion, but hints into this direction.
So no, we do not agree with the points made
by the authors here that actual generalization
happens.
It might very well be that we mean something
different with “generalization”, we think.
But the point of the authors maybe is that
by varying the training set, one can increase
performance on out-of-domain tasks.
But Ms. Coffee Bean is allergic to these big
words and argues that this is not the point
of generalization, because generalization
happens when the model “got it” and found
the algorithm behind eigenvalue decomposition
and can apply it successfully to really unseen
distributions.
But yes, it is too much to expect, sure.
And if we are already at the generalization
buzzword, let’s go to the next buzzword:
Few-shot.
The argument of the authors here is that the
models trained on small matrices (5 x 5) do
not generalize to larger matrices.
Then the model trained on 40 million examples
can be further trained to also solve bigger
matrices with about 25 million more examples.
Ok.
Sounds fair.
But what does not sound fair is that this
is put into relation with the word few-shot!
Is 25M examples few-shot now!?
Is it just Ms. Coffee Bean for whom few-shot
is at most 20 or okay, 100 examples?
Since when is few-shot in the order of millions
and more than half the amount of training
data during initial training?
What do you think?
What is “few” in few-shot?
And is this successful out-of-domain generalization
as presented in the paper, or just wishful
thinking but not quite?
Or let’s make “generalization” less
of a binary variable, so we want to ask you:
how much percent generalization is here?
Let us know what you think in the comments.
Ok, Ms. Coffee Bean, the terminology police-coffee-bean
will go now.
Do not take her too serious on her rants about
buzzwords.
I am writing papers myself and I must admit
that buzzwords… help!
If these are loosely defined, evolving, and
changing overused words, why not use them
to one’s own advantage?
Hey, Ms. Coffee Bean, you still here?
Yes you are, because you have something to
tell:
Look, we have been doing this AI Coffee Break
Quiz on our community tab for quite a while
now.
We have posted over 200 questions there already.
And yes, we are kind of running out of ideas.
So if you, dear audience member, want to contribute
over there and you have an idea for a question,
just email us and we will post it [the suggestion]
and we will also credit you.
Okay, bye!